l'ex président a donné son avis sur la
politique du président de la république
le flou n'est pas un projet l'élection
présidentielle ait un rendez vous manqué
il n'y a pas eu de grands débats d'idées
et la crédibilité des programmes étaient
évacués emmanuel macron dit j'applique
mon projet mais le quel point jean
emmanuel macron n'est vraiment pas au
niveau des enjeux dont je viens de base
alors je dis pas qu'ils emmanuel macron
il est parfait mais je vais vous dire
c'est comme si
nicolas pernikoff donner des conseils au
tennis à rodger federer
le gars il en a pas mille une dedans non
mais c'est incroyable et il vient et
c'est cavani qui donne des conseils mba
pays tu sais pas mais c'est vrai leur
cabane il est incroyable c'est que ni la
c1 cardy cap amiens mutuel va donner les
conseils mbappé tu ne regrettes tu veux
pas fermer ta gueule ou ça non mais sans
déconner françois hollande alors
françois hollande c'est le donneur de
leçons il arrive voilà bah après lui n'a
pas bien fait après il a continué bien
dans son interview pour les prêts
express s'est montré particulièrement
sévère avec les mesures prises par le
gouvernement ont subventionné
durablement les prix pour éviter
l'inflation comme nous sommes en train
de le faire quitte à creuser chaque fois
peu plus le bon voilà en fait il nous
fait chier quand je savais par écrit
nous fait chier voilà moi je suis et
c'est donc si en fait il est devenu
chroniqueur maintenant que tmx les
chroniqueurs télé m'avait des boîtes des
samu et perd arrête
arrête tu es marié était bien le drive à
faire chier le monde dresse les gens
travaillent et non mais c'est vrai tu as
eu cinq ans pour faire le boulot et
n'était même pas représenté derrière
c'est comme s'il était un régate est
champion du monde là l'équipe sont
plaints des moyens dit non je n'ai pas
la coupe du monde l'année d'après
tellement je sais que je vais prendre
une tôle non mais c'est incroyable mais
et macron il va malheureusement il bat
italienne car la vérité takm ce qu'il
était dans son gouvernement et après il
s'est rendu compte que vous étiez
tellement nulle kipre voilà qui s'est
dit à une brèche célibat je me présente
et il a été élu il a été élu deux fois
bon après voilà on n'aime pas qu'on
n'aime pas en tout cas ce que je suis
sur moi je défends jamais le
gouvernement d'un jeu le fond des buts
bernier tout le monde ni personne mais
en tout cas ce que c'est c'est qu'ils
font rarement françois hollande non mais
c'est vrai les gars qu'ils ne cèderont
peu plus des donneurs de leçons le gaz
nul et il se permet de donner des leçons
françois hollande non mes frères va
faire des floralies
[Applaudissements]
des soirées manuel mâcon encore nicolas
sarkozy dit la vérité voilà nicolas
sarkozy il a marqué son quinquennat
voilà c'est un président nicolas sarkozy
5 c'est un patron ça va ça bosse
certains thoniers l'autre frère et il
comprend bien jean-luc mélenchon tu
aimes ou tu aimes pas voilà moi je suis
si vous savez que j'aime bien jean luc
mélenchon c'est un pote qui me fait
marrer il envoie chier les gens dans la
rue démarrant
où le cac comme moi il est marrant
voilà jean luc mélenchon jean luc
mélenchon est là quelque chose dont il
met en scène tu dis voilà c'est quand
même un mec qui n'y voient la lumière à
tous les étages non mais l'autre il a
été président frère il a le plus gros
coup de chaque histoire
de la présidentielle peut arriver j'ai
réuni chaque pareil non mais franchement
d'asma possible il ya de lachenaie de
danielle moores
[Applaudissements]
il a d'ailleurs il s'est très bien lui
même qu'il a une chatouille c'est pas pr
nombre d'anomalies ça arrive une fois on
a vu ces monadnocks haye et on n'a vu
rien continue à elle continue à donner
des 100 emmanuel macron auxerre gérait
alors votre ami
bien pensée et bien compris que vous
n'aimiez pas françois hollande mais
enfin les mecs truc c'est que je pense
que moi il nous sommes pas non plus ça
va peut-être jour nous ne sommes pas non
plus en tout cas il était chroniqueur
chez le côté d'un taux scholly l'année
prochaine ils dorment à singer dans des
collèges épaules et la toile bleue mais
tant pis je l'aurais
tournay président même si on les a
trouvés incompétent droite donné quand
même leur arrivée mais qu'il arrête le
défi mais il n'arrête pas de le donner
et c'est un donneur de leçons là mais
quand tu es quand avec pas été capable
de te représenter tu fermes ta gueule et
tu va recueillir des pommes de terre
comme gilbert baisse de week-end mais
c'est tout c'est pas pire que sarkozy
paraguay 3e circuit
mais sarkozy sarko dit il on le voit
qu'il est compétent c'est le gars et
frère il a les a tous ratés il a raté
deux belles s'il a raté le père bill a
raté sa borne ils veulent de nous casser
les couilles décollé
[Applaudissements]
de trahir son camp est-ce que c'est
beaucoup mieux mais pas trop tout ce qui
s'est dit ma croûte vous dire la vérité
macro est d'avis que c'est tellement une
quiche chaude c'est dit c'est lui mon
chef c'est inutile tiens comme c'est ici
j'sais pas
[Applaudissements]
la voilà on avait un gala non mais ça
non mais c'est vrai il s'est dit c'est
tellement des quiches que je peux être
président en fait c'est tout ce qu'il
est ici il n'était pas et n'est pas du
milieu manuel mâcon il était hors
politique et aideront à financer car il
a vu il signe au bout de deux mois et
s'est dit mais qu'est ce que
j'en rigolais loti comprend lé président
milan 1 mais je suis dit je vais
lesquels n'en faites pas ça il n'a pas
été mauvais hollande hollande mais bien
si on va prendre ça bien qu'il ya un
truc fait été commandés françois
françois hollande arrête à françois
hollande il dira jamais non mais moi
je veux dire on va chez jura non plus
dans un trimestre a toujours une bonne
note t'es à côté d'eux sais pas pourquoi
tu as 18 sur marathon c'est plus qu'il
m'amène à inonder les jets à côté d'eux
mêmes de la bonne personne c'est tout
non mais le problème est qu'à toucher du
doigt le problème c'est que c'est un
manuel et entaché sa parole elle
entachée parce qu'on a le sentiment qu à
chaque fois c'est de la vengeance est
vrai qu'en fait c'est personnel et par
une histoire son volet français lui donc
voilà c'est va pas faire un débat sur
françois hollande
alors mais si on peut quand même un peu
nuancer sa com était un président de la
république
est donc généralement les anciens
présidents donne toujours le maximum sur
reçu alors aussi alors je pense que ce
soit hollande pendant son mandat m ce
n'est pas d'accord avec lui parce qu'il
ya il ya je sens que nicolas sarkozy
donnait aussi régulièrement wallace a
reconnu son erreur
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il m'a dit tu prenais des risques mais
c'est vrai dagenais hadary sur maïdan
mais alors oui mais ça
aussi on en france pour l'instant des
français jusqu'à aller on savait les
deux hommes sinclair il
en
tant qu'etat tu me fais plaisir gilbert
vais vous faire une confidence est le
seul vote que je regrette pas ce que
j'ai voté pour lui c'est le seul gros tu
as voté pour lui mais c'était faux
bruits ont embrouillé au q1 au niveau
des votes
l'habitude de dévoiler me des votes
répondez-lui moi je
[Rires]
sais c'est que l'on aime et 100 ha oui
pourquoi pas d'iphone ont
ils senti
les bonus nommé prétentieux en plus de m
je vais tenter le ghana c'est un truc de
fou leader et je dis ça je dis bon allez
c'est pas dur je n'ai pas envie de le
connaître je m'épanouis les connecteurs
et bah oui et oui nous snobent par
ségolène ségolène et d'ailleurs je me
demande ce qu'elle faisait avec ce
faisant un
problème j'adore ségolène arrêté le
premier modèle est incroyable c'est elle
qui tire est tiré vers le haut sans
déconner dommage qu'elle n'ait pas été
président croyable ségolène ap la
bravitude alors qu'est ce que j'en ai à
[ __ ]
et on respecte un petit peu ce doublé la
fonction oui la fonction
tout cela bien sûr on peut pas le prime
c'est qu'ils parlent trop tous les jours
il prend la parole est vrai un truc un
coup c'est pour une bd parce qu'il va
doubler un dessin animé c'est vrai qu'il
est chroniqueur à l'opinion il passe sa
vie sur le plateau et en fait cette sur
médiatisation c'est ça qui décrédibilise
la parole va bien charles pauze il parle
beaucoup moins souvent et quand il parle
on l'écoutera la verge il est visible
dans les médias jours ici et s'il
donnait des leçons pareil ici qu'est ce
que tu dirais je lui dirai va même
[Rires]
on
l'a souvent manuel valls quand même
beaucoup et ségolène royal j'espère qu'à
venir bientôt aussi j'adore voilà mes
françois hollande ferait plaisir autant
faire c'est un truc de fou aller et tout
citoyen donnent leur avis sur la
politique de mâcon pourquoi lui pourrait
pas la donne est ce parce qu'il la donne
trop exigu jaloux tous les jours pas si
tu vas pas était dépressive
[Rires]
tu vois pas d'où sort de quatre jours de
pita diffusé en direct encore les
perfusions tu m'as donné tout est déjà
monté la pièce
mon gré n'est géré à l'essai nous a
remonté la pente après jonathan papelbon
l'autre
futur transpire bah oui elle y aller
sans aimer faire affront faire c'est une
patinoire sur la botanique